so when you know if you watch yourself
you say well I had a particularly good
day at work
and what does that mean well it means
that you lost your sense of time right
because when you're having not a good
day at work it's like first it's one
minute to three and then it's 45 seconds
to three and then it's 30 seconds that's
what school was like for me it was like
clique so funny you know I went to I
went to my daughter's school I used to
get in trouble for talking all the time
it's probably surprise when I was a kid
and and I was bored stiff in school and
and so I would misbehave upon occasion
out of pure boredom and about 21 years
ago I went to my daughter's school to
sit for a class it was about an hour
long and I was sitting there and the
teacher had all the kids on the floor
and was having some of the kids read to
the others and some of the kids who were
reading couldn't read at all and I had
exactly the same experience I was
sitting there it was like being it's
like being seven years old again I could
see the clock going tick tick and I
thought you know if I was in this
classroom for three days I would
misbehave but fit 40 years old I would
misbehave exactly like I did when I was
when I was six
No well that's no place to be right
because that's you don't want to be in a
place that's stultifying you don't want
to be in a place where there's no
challenge you might even quit your job
if there's no challenge say well that's
a good job it gives you security and you
think god I can't stand this it's eating
away at my soul
it's all security and no challenge so
why do you want to challenge because
that's what you're built for that's what
you're built for you're built to take on
a maximal load right because that's what
strengthens you and you need to be
strong because life is extraordinarily
difficult and because the evil king is
always whittling away at the structure
of the state and you have to be awake
and sharp to stop that from happening so
that you don't become corrupt and so
that your family doesn't become
corrupt and so that your state doesn't
have to become become corrupt you have
to have your eyes open and your wit
sharp and your words at the ready and
you have to be educated and you have to
know about your history and you have to
know how to think and you have to know
how to read and you have to know how to
speak and you have to know how to aim
and you have to be willing to hoist the
troubles of the world up on your
shoulders and what's so interesting
about that so remarkable and and this is
something that's really manifested
itself to me as I've been doing these
public lectures I've been talking about
responsibility to people which doesn't
seem to happen very often anymore and
the audiences are dead quiet and I lay
out this idea that life is tragedy
tainted by malevolence and everyone says
yeah well we already always suspected
that but no one has ever said it quite
so bluntly and it's quite a relief to
hear that I'm not the only person who
has those suspicions and then the second
part of that is the better part in its
the optimistic part which is despite the
fact that life is a tragedy tainted by
malevolence at every level of existence
there's something about the human spirit
that can thrive under precisely those
conditions if we allow that to occur
because as difficult as life is and as
horrible as we are our capacity to deal
with that catastrophe and to transcend
that malevolent spirit is more powerful
than than that reality itself and that's
the fundamental issue I think that's the
fundamental issue of the judeo-christian
ethic with its emphasis on the divinity
of the individual as catastrophic as
life is and as malevolent as people can
be and that's malevolent beyond belief
fundamentally the person has in spirit
the nobility to set that right and to
defeat evil and that and that more than
that and that the antidote to the
catastrophe of life and the suffering of
life and the tragedy of life that can
drive you down and destroy you is to
take on exactly that responsibility and
to say well there's plenty of work to be
done and isn't that terrible and there
isn't anything so bad that we can't make
it worse insert
they try very hard to do so but I have
it within me to decide that I'm going to
stand up against that I'm going to
strive to make the world a better place
I'm going to strive to constrain the
malevolence that's in my own heart and
to set my family straight and to work to
work despite my tragic lot for the
betterment of anything of everything
that's in front of me and the
consequence of that the immediate
consequence of that is that when you
make the decision to take on all of that
voluntarily which is to stand up
straight by the way with your shoulders
back to take on that all that on
voluntarily as soon as you make that
decision then all the catastrophe
justifies itself in the nobility of your
striving and that's what it means to be
an individual thank you